what's up everybody how you doing today
as most of you saw on Twitter and
Facebook this is going to be a season
seven predictions video but it's going
to be slightly different than the normal
prediction videos that I do because in
this one I'm going to be answering all
those burning questions that most people
have wanted to know ever since season
six ended and this might actually end up
being a two-part video considering the
amount of questions that I got so let's
not waste any more time and get right
into this the first question is from
Nick Williams and he asked do you think
they will bring Roberts bastard back he
left in a boat we haven't heard anything
since I say yes again jury is going to
come back and not only is Gendry going
to return to the show I think he's going
to end up in a significantly powerful
position when it's all said and done I
think Jon Snow or Daenerys Targaryen is
going to end up legitimizing injury and
given him his own land in the end
possibly even storm's end the second
question is from kam and he said who do
you think is going to be sitting on the
Iron Throne at the end of season 7
honestly I think Cersei will still be
sitting on the Iron Throne but she will
have taken a lot of losses by then she's
going to be hanging on by a thin thread
and if she does align herself when
you're on by the end of season 7 he
might actually be dead and by then
Daenerys will have gained the entire
north on her side so although Cersei
will still have King's Landing at the
end of season seven Circe's army will be
much smaller and she will have no allies
and I think at the very beginning of
season 8 that's going to decide her fate
in my opinion then one Cersei is out of
the way everyone can actually focus on
the threat up north okay next question
we're in Westeros do you think Daenerys
will land with her army I think Daenerys
is going to land on Dragonstone but I do
not think she will land there with her
entire army I think she's going to split
up her forces before she gets there in
an attempt to secure some of the
surrounding areas around King's Landing
I think Daenerys will try to control or
form an alliance with each and every
territory in Westeros before she goes
and strikes King's Landing I think she
wants to give Cersei no place to run and
no option but to surrender re moving on
Jaime asked does bran get to Winterfell
are we having a literal
starke reunion will mirror read stay
with him
yes brand we'll get to Winterfell I say
by mid-season we will have a reunion
between brand songs and Aria but John
will not reunite with them until season
8 I think as soon as John leaves for
Dragonstone that's when the Starks are
going to start showing up at Winterfell
then when John leaves Dragonstone he's
probably going to head straight for the
wall so he can go north John's going to
be a very busy man next season so they
will more than likely tease his reunion
with them but we won't actually get it
until season 8 in my opinion also I
think once mirror Reed helps escort bran
back to Winterfell she's going to head
home her mission was the help bran get
to the three-eyed raven so now that it's
accomplished she will probably want to
go back home the next question is from
Jonathan and he asked who will really
help out what the White was in the south
and as most of the north still really
was him that's a good question
considering Daenerys doesn't know John
and she's so focused on getting the Iron
Throne right now she might be a little
hesitant with helping John but I think
Tyrion is going to be the key figure
he's going to be the glue that gets
Damaris and John to stick together and I
know Tyrion and John don't know each
other extremely well but they did grow
fond of each other and also grew to
respect each other with a little bit of
time that they did spend with each other
at the wall
I think Tyrion is going to ensure that
Daenerys will give John a chance also
even though Tyrion didn't believe in the
White Walkers at first if you remember
correctly when Tyrion told Cersei that
the Nights Watch needed help
Cersei told Tyrion not to believe in her
stories but Tyrians mind had slightly
changed since he visited the wall and he
told Cersei Lord come in to Mormont
would not lie about the threat
so if Jon does tell Daenerys he needs
help Tyrion will be the one willing to
believe his story also Varys could be
willing to help out John Varys seems to
know everyone's secrets so I think
there's a very good chance that he knows
not only who John is but he may even
know his true lineage so since Varys is
on this mission of a Targaryen
restoration he could be willing to help
John as well he could help Tyrion
influence Daenerys his decision was
sending men north to help against the
night
me and you also asked if most of the
north is still really with John well
even though the veil helped John when
the Battle of the bastards
I don't think Littlefinger is going to
willingly help John out anymore it's no
secret that Littlefinger was not pleased
with John becoming King in the north
so as soon as John leaves for
Dragonstone I think Littlefinger is
going to start hatching another plan
that will oppose John something will
have to be done with Littlefinger in
order to get the veil back under control
and fighting for the north because I
think while Littlefinger is in charge of
the veil they probably won't be there
when John needs them again but that's
just my opinion of course all right the
next question is from Pei true or P true
sorry I'm not sure how to pronounce your
name but he asks what will happen to the
night's king in the end hopefully he
gets his ass kicked if you haven't seen
any of my other videos about this I
think the night King and John Snow are
going to end up fighting each other one
verse one in the most epic sword fight
we have ever seen ever since I saw the
episode in art home and Jon Snow and the
19 had that 10th stair down I've always
thought we would get a big payoff scene
of those two meeting on the battlefield
and fighting each other but also said in
another video that I'm not so sure but
my team can be defeated by a Valyrian
steel sword
we know that the White Walkers can be
killed with Valyrian steel but since the
making is the most powerful of them all
he may not be able to be killed by the
same weapons as the White Walkers how
crazy would it be if Jon Snow went to
slice the night king with long haul but
the night king shattered his Valyrian
steel sword like it was any other weapon
I think that would be insane maybe the
night king can only be killed by light
bringer or a dragon fire we have seen
the making walk through fire and
basically extinguish it so it would
probably take fire from a dragon to
affect him but either way I think the
xix will be defeated by Jon Snow in one
way or another even if Jon has to ride a
damn dragon by himself
alright the next question is from
Rebecca Miller and she asked if Arya is
dead could someone be wearing her face
so that the faceless men had been in at
Winterfell the answer is no Arya is not
dead Arya is definitely still alive she
was not killed by the wave I think if
Arya
is dead then why would the person
wearing her face go and kill Walder Frey
what motivation would they had to do
that Oreo was the one who had beef with
the phrase so it wouldn't make sense for
someone else to go out of their way to
kill them that was definitely Arya she's
back in with her vengeance okay the next
question is from a you pack mule and for
any of you hardcore Game of Thrones fans
you probably refer to him as John he
also makes Game of Thrones videos on
YouTube if you haven't already
definitely go check out a you pack mules
channel he's been doing this amazing
series of videos on his channel he's
doing 30 live streams and if I'm not
mistaken he has had a different game of
Thrones youtuber on each of those videos
which is a great idea if you ask me so
for any of my strong supporters out
there do me a favor and go subscribe to
AU pack mules Channel let's see if we
can get him a hundred new subscribers
today that would be amazing and I would
really appreciate it if you guys could
do that but let's get into his question
because it's not going to be an easy one
to answer au pack mule asked me what
will be the best one-on-one battle and
what weapons will be used I actually had
to take some time to think about this
one because there are so many
possibilities we have dire wolves
Valyrian steel swords crossbows dragons
wild fire and there were more than
likely be a naval battle with your own
next season and many other things could
take place but since this was a season 7
question I had to keep it very specific
so I'm going to have to say the best
one-on-one battle next season is going
to be Jon Snow verse another white
Walker and I wanted to say you're on
verse Dany sleep because I think when
you're on a tax part of her fleet we
could see something epic but that's not
really a one verse one and I also wanted
to pick a dragon as the weapon but it
will more than likely be torching more
than just one person at a time so that's
not really one verse one either so I had
to go with something that will more than
likely happen in the biggest episode
Game of Thrones tends to have their
biggest battles right before the finale
so if Jon Snow is really going to go on
this mission north of the wall during
episode six next season then that
episode will be the one that raises the
stakes and has one of the more tense
battles and since they are going to be
capturing a white they're more than
likely going to come into contact with
some White Walkers - Jon will be the
only one with a Valyrian steel sword
so unless they take some dragonglass
with them from Dragonstone John's going
to be the only one equipped to kill away
Walker and I think we could see a much
better sword fight than the first time
John fought one and hardhome so that's
my answer John snows gonna kill at least
one more white Walker next season in
epic fashion ok the next question is
from ls and she said who will you're on
try to marry Yara off - since she will
be his prisoner honestly I don't think
he's going to try to marry her to anyone
but I do think Iran will try to use Yara
in another way he will use her and the
sand snakes in order to form an alliance
with Cersei but then I think Yara is
going to be used as a negotiation tactic
Yara will be used to bargain with
Damaris Damaris and Yara seem to really
hit it off on a first met so Daenerys
will be wanting to get her back safely
more than likely which will give Euron
and Cersei some leverage when it comes
to negotiating or agreeing to some kind
of terms so no I don't think your is
going to be married off to anybody but I
do think you're on will use her in some
type of way in the next question Chris
says now that the stark girls are all
grown up do I think we will get any
nudity is that creepy no but it is funny
it's a legitimate question considering
HBO and Game of Thrones especially is
known for having a significant amount of
nudity Emilia Clarke who plays Daenerys
Targaryen as one of the show's biggest
stars and she's been new several times
so it's not crazy to think some of the
other stars from the show could get nude
too but the question was do I think
either of the stark girls will go nude
now that they're of age personally I
don't think so I'm not sure why they
would need to have really wouldn't serve
much purpose to the story unless they
just wanted to create some kind of a
buzz about it on the Internet and I just
don't see Arya or songs of being in any
position to where they would need to be
nude so no I don't think so sir I don't
think we're going to see that Cornelia
says Walder Frey is confirmed to be in
season 7 do I think that means Arya is
going to wear his face and wipe out the
rest of house Frey or will he just be
there for a funeral scene personally I
think it's just going to be a funeral
scene I highly doubt Arya is going to
wear his face and if it's not a funeral
scene I think it might just be somebody
discovering his body in the dining hall
next morning someone may just walk in
and see him slumped over on a table I
think that's about all we're going to
see a world of rain next season but I
could be wrong maybe she does wear his
face but I really don't think so next
question is from Ollie
he says before Littlefinger goes down he
has to do something huge perhaps kill
someone in his way someone who is
important but whom
that's a good question Littlefinger
needs to be doing something next season
especially if they're going to kill him
off by the end of it I think he may try
to have sweet Robin killed that way he
has full control of the veil he may even
have Lord Royce killed just to get him
out of the way to Littlefinger isn't
going to want to lose the control he
does have over that army and I think if
he feels he has lost total control over
Shawn's up then he may try to position
himself with someone else while keeping
the veil and even a little finger has
major influence over sweet wabun right
now if these fears that songs that can
tell him some of his dirty little
secrets he may have him tossed out that
damn moon door before Robin can turn the
veil against Littlefinger sweet Robins
never going to step foot on the
battlefield and the north is definitely
going to need to Vale to fight the night
king so I don't see sweet Robin serving
any purpose during season eight anyway
so they're probably going to kill sweet
Robin and have John or song to take
control over the Vale before the final
war begins okay moving on camera asked
when do you think John's going to find
out that he is a Targaryen I don't think
we'll get that big reveal until season 8
it's going to be teased are in season
seven through possible reunions but bran
is it going to make it back to
Winterfell until John has already left
to go meet Daenerys I think once John
leaves Winterfell he's not going to be
back to Winterfell until season eight
he's going to be down in Dragonstone for
a few episodes probably then he's
probably going to send a raven telling
Foreman and the other men to meet him at
the wall so they can go north
he may even send some of the men to the
wall before he leaves Winterfell but
when and if they capture this white they
will probably take it straight back to
King's Landing to show everyone that
it's real John's going to be very busy
next season so I doubt he will reunite
with Brandon Arya in time before he
leaves Winterfell
I would love for him to find out he's
half Targaryen as soon as possible but
the show is going to build that up some
more in
use it with her I want to apologize to
this next person I have no idea how to
pronounce your name but I'll take a stab
at it anyway duro Wei asked if Stannis
Dumanis will return next season I would
love to see Stannis again but I don't
think we're going through even though
his quote unquote death was off screen I
just don't see them bringing him back at
this point but if you are a big Stannis
fan and you haven't read the books
definitely go check out those books
because Stannis is still alive and
kick'n joanna or johanna asked if bran
and Jaime will meet face to face next
season if so does bran remember what
happened to him
I actually just made a video about this
a few days ago
I do not think bran remembers but if he
saw Jaime's face again it probably would
finally hit him that this is the man who
pushed him that day but I highly doubt
they're going to meet face to face next
season it's going to take brand a few
episodes to make it back to Winterfell
and once brain gets there he probably
won't leave for the rest of the season
and Jaime is going to be down south most
of the season if not all of the season
Jaime's going to be down in the reach
taking Highgarden then he's probably
going to go back to King's Landing with
Cersei then more than likely he'll be at
the dragon pit scene in the finale so I
don't think Jamie's going to be in the
north at all not yet at least
if they do cross paths again it won't be
until season eight okay the next
question is from another name I can't
pronounce so I'll just say your twitter
name the question is from dose of over
it says shall we see the fight between
Robert and Rhaegar next season I would
be geeked if we actually get to see this
the illustrations alone are incredible
but I just don't think we're going to
see this next season but we could see
the 20 of Harrenhal
bran they learn more about what happened
with Leone and Rhaegar since John being
a Targaryen is pretty important to the
story if we ever see a live-action fight
between Robert and Rhaegar it will more
than likely be in the spin-off series
for Robert's rebellion all right I'll do
one more question then I'll save the
rest for another video
this one's from Chris and he said what
do you think will happen when an F or
Ian meets Melisandre I think this all
depends on when arya runs into her again
if arya finds out Gendry is still alive
and if she finds out Melisandre brought
John back to life then she probably
wouldn't kill her but if R er one
to Melisandre before she finds out
anything that Melisandre is probably
going to be killed unless Melisandre is
traveling with her necklace off and she
appears to be an old lady then Arya
could cross paths with her and not even
know it's her I'm thinking we could get
this seen fairly early on in the season
though since Arya is heading north and
Melisandre should be heading south
Jon told her to go south but that
doesn't mean she will but we should see
this within the first few episodes and
if they do meet again Melisandre will
more than likely be killed by Arya
unless she's able to convince her
otherwise Ahri folks I think that's
enough for one video I want to thank
everyone who submitted their questions I
appreciate all the feedback and great
questions you guys gave if I didn't get
to yours in this video I will save it
for the next one comment below and give
me your opinions what do you think
wiping with some of these scenarios let
me know your thoughts thanks again and I
will see you down in the comments bye
you